missiles fires and fear for three weeks
this has been the reality for those
living in war zones across ukraine
once again russian artillery fire
continues to strike on the edges of the
ukrainian capital
western intelligence indicates the
russian invasion in many areas has
stalled and key cities including keefe
where the 35 hour curfew lifted thursday
remain in ukrainian control
control however doesn't mean safety
the enemy makes no success and they
cannot get those cities and for that
reason they start terrorist actions they
start just coertically imprecisely
shelling those cities from their
artillery and with their missiles it
seems what russia can't capture
it destroys
unconfirmed reports say at least 21 were
killed in this strike east of keefe
in nearby harkeef where there's little
left to reduce to ruins smoke continues
to fill the sky the beribashova market
once considered one of the largest in
europe is in flames after a missile
strike the fire spread to nearby homes
i don't even know what to say the fire
is here and there you have to drive
around and see
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
again visited a hospital his staff
released these images the visit followed
yet another direct and impassioned
address to western politicians
this time he's imploring germany's
leader to take more action
you are again behind the wall not the
berlin one but in the middle of europe
between freedom and captivity and it is
growing with every bomb on our land
the bombardments are ongoing and deadly
the u.n has confirmed that more than 700
civilians have died so far and more than
eleven hundred have been injured
and the real yet to be verified numbers
are likely to be much higher
tracy
crystal commansing reporting in london
thank you crystal